[Music]
hello everyone.welcome to see each ATS
hosted by cloud on-air live webinars
from Google cloud we're hosting webinars
every Tuesday my name is Brandon Guevara
I'm a cloud customer engineer at Google
and joining me today is Morgan McLean
who is a product manager here at Google
as well today we're going to be talking
you about open census just a quick
reminder for everybody who's watching
the stream live you can ask questions
any time on the platform and we have
Googlers
on standby to answer those questions for
you so let's go ahead and get started hi
everyone
so as Brandon mentioned my name is
Morgan McLean I'm the product manager
for open census which is what we're
talking about today I'm also the product
manager for our stackdriver APM line
which includes stackdriver trace
debugger and profiler so let's get
started and dive into open sentence
let's do it so for those who don't know
open census is a set of telemetry
collection libraries we'll get into what
exactly that means in a minute but to
start I just want to talk about the
journey of how we arrived at this so
inside of Google we use technologies
like distributed tracing and application
metrics and distributed metrics and one
of the challenges that we perceived at
Google a number of years ago was
actually collecting telemetry from our
applications so in order to capture
things like a distributed trace which
tracks a request as it propagates across
services you have to have a bunch of
integrations into all of the sort of
network interactions that you have on
your system and this is difficult so we
created a project called census open
census is effectively an externalization
of this and this is part of a
longer-term trend at Google like if you
look at kubernetes for example it's
effectively an externalization of Borg
which is our container management system
G RPC is an externalization is something
internal called stubby which does our
pcs
open sense this is just another part of
that same story and so we're hoping to
share the same benefits that we've
received at Google from census with our
customers and with the world through
open census so let's dive into sort of
your traditional application as they
were developed a few years ago so most
things were built as a monolith this can
be anything from a client application on
a phone or even you know basic web
services back in the day
where
you would go and build a single large
self-contained application these are
fairly easy to get observability and
it'll Emma tree into this is being you
know perfected over a number of years
where if you want to understand how the
parts of your app interact with each
other you can do things like collect a
stack trace from an exception or from a
break point and testing in staging or
non production environments it's also
fairly straightforward with these
monolithic applications there's a lot of
good solutions there but as you know
most of our viewers are more than aware
everyone's been shifting to micro
services over the last few years and
this is for good reasons micro services
are much easier to operate at scale
they're much more maintainable when you
have to build an apple pies the larger
application that handles you know
hundreds thousands tens of thousands
requests per second right and so like
micro services are generally really good
in really powerful architecture but one
of the challenges of micro services is
actually being able to manage them in
games or ability into what's happening
so a lot of those lessons or those
techniques that we had in the past where
we try and you know capture a trace like
a stack trace of your application are no
longer really applicable if we have the
application that you see here with
services a B and C and you understand
for a particular request of a particular
customer interaction how those services
interact
capturing a stack trace from like
service see isn't that valuable because
you don't know what happened on the
client or a and B and so techniques like
distributed tracing had to be invented
for that distributed tracing was
certainly popular as popularized by
Google we published a paper back and I
think 2010 about the dapper tracing
system that exists inside of a company
and what it allows you to do is
understand how these requests flow
across systems so for example if you
have some kind of interaction you're
curious about a service see you could
see I request a single you can capture a
single customer request that stems from
your client app this goes to service a
does some processing there it goes to
service B does some processing there it
maybe calls up to serve a scene database
in parallel and the distributed trace
will show you that across all of these
applications awesome another really
useful thing that's difficult to do is
distributed metrics right so for our
monolith
all we would need to do is capture
things like latency metrics for the
entire app that's relatively
straightforward but in a microservices
world we actually want to capture for
example latency metrics from
each individual service it's not enough
to understand that you know one of the
endpoints exposed by service a is slow
in this example we also want to
understand which interactions on service
B and C are slow and so not just
understanding that B and C themselves
are slow but like if the actual
endpoints exposed by B and C we want to
see latency and sort of statistics about
the our PCs and so there's a lot of
complexity here to build this kind of to
get this kind of instrumentation out of
your app you have to go and build it so
this involves getting integrations and
if you want it automatically it involves
getting integrations into various web
frameworks RPC frameworks storage
clients and other client libraries that
your application uses and this is
annoying and difficult and this is one
of the reasons that things like
distributed tracing historically haven't
been that popular at smaller companies
it's just too expensive to get going and
so with open census we're making this a
lot more accessible so with open census
we give you automatic instrumentation we
give you ap eyes and exporters to hand
in your data and I'll dive into this
what these mean in a minute but at its
core open census is a set of language
specific instrumentation libraries so we
have libraries for Java nodejs
we're building one for dotnet we also go
C++ Python Ruby and PHP and so we have a
lot of coverage across all these
languages we have libraries that you
just link to your application again to
get the sort of observability and
insight into your app each of these
libraries once linked to your
application will automatically traces
and RPC related metrics from your
application so for example we've
integrations for various HTTP clients
for GRDC for things like MongoDB where
as a developer once you've linked the
library to your app you do no additional
work we automatically will capture
traces and propagate contexts and things
like that
for those who aren't aware just when I
say what context propagation what that
means is to capture that request that
goes from A to B to C into the database
you need to pass some kind of identifier
or something so that you can actually
correlate all of those requests later
the next thing that opens senses
provides is api's so not only do we
automatically collect a lot of
information from your application we
also let you manually interact of that
so if you're eight with the API is you
can do things like define a custom stat
or custom metric and to send that to
back in you can manually add spans or
components to your traces things that
weren't automatically captured or
long-running processes that you want to
you want to capture it as a part of the
trace and you can add custom metadata or
custom tags to both of these you can
also configure things of the api's so
traces that I mentioned before
distributed traces or not we don't
capture every request generally with
most tracing systems are something
called sampling where roughly on average
1% of the requests are actually traced
this is to reduce costs and reduce the
performance impact of tracing the API is
an open census allow you to configure
this manually finally there kind of
another key part of open census is
exporters so rather than just sending
data back to stackdriver back to a
particular back-end open census sends
data to your back-end of choice this is
why open census it's not just a Google
project we're actually participating
with a number of vendors though we were
certainly the initiators of it so if
open census you can send data back to
Zipkin or Prometheus which are the main
open source backends that we target so
all features for open census have to
work for ZIP code in Prometheus you can
also send data back to stack driver of
course but you cannot you can send it
your telemetry back to data dog
SolarWinds Yeager and a number of other
backends for processing could you send
them to multiple at the same time you
can and we'll go into that in a minute
so the benefits of that but you can you
know a really common use case for open
census is sending data to zip kin for
tracing and Prometheus for stats right
and so you can send you know staffs to
one back-end and trace this to another
you can also just sense that send that
to multiple even at the same time
awesome we'll go into that in a minute
but yeah it's a good question it's a
really powerful feature so as I
mentioned before we've really great
support for Java C++ and go open census
has already had tracing support and not
staff support but tracing support for
Ruby Python and PHP though we're adding
stats those now I think stats was just
added to Python last week so I should
pup database deck and finally we have
full support under development for no GS
and dotnet the no GS client also just
went into alpha so you can go use it
it's just in a very early state of
course open census has a ton of
integrations there's far too many to
list but we effectively cover all HTTP G
RPC sequel clients you know
storage clients like MongoDB and various
web frameworks the web framework
integrations are there to get you
automatic context propagation so you
don't have to manually correlate an
incoming request of an outgoing one in
order to get a trace that's a really
like it sounds trivial that's actually a
really powerful feature hoping census is
just removing that work that you have to
do finally we have many exporters so of
course are sort of native open-source
exporters who are for Zipkin in
Prometheus but we also support Jaeger
signal FX data dog SolarWinds in Stannah
Amazon x-ray and of course the sector
ever and as us do you can use multiple
of these you can mix and match and used
it once at the same time which is really
nice so we're gonna do a demo of open
census I'm gonna show you both the
telemetry that we've captured and how
easy it was to get configured the demo
app for this is gonna be hipster shop
which we'll show you in a minute if you
tuned into next basically any of the
presentations are next they use tipster
shop it's a new demo app that we've
created for GCP and it's an e-commerce
system that's deployed across a number
of different micro services and
kubernetes so it's got a front end
written and go and then it has several
back-end services written in Python
nodejs go and dotnet core as I mentioned
before it's all running on kubernetes
and it uses a combination of HTTP and GG
RPC to communicate between these
services so the front-end will talk to
web browsers and HTTP obviously but the
service interactions inside of the
application are both an HTTP and g RPC
and so this is a great test bed for open
census because it has to do things like
propagate context and capture traces
across those different RPC mechanisms
which is traditionally not that easy it
also uses various GCP client libraries
and it can track requests across those
this particular demonstration of hipster
shop doesn't use an external database
but rest assured we do support basically
all sequel clients and things like
MongoDB and other storage clients so
let's hop to the demo so this is the
hipster shop app again if you watched GC
Phoenix at all you're probably
intimately familiar with it this is the
slow version of hipster shop that we
used in one of the keynotes when we use
the stack driver APM tools to diagnose
it we're using it for this demonstration
of open census because
as a part of being slow it generates
really nice telemetry for us to inspect
so to start we're gonna look at traces
so this is stackdriver trace again with
open census you can use any tracing back
end like Zipkin or others and what we're
using stackdriver for this demo it's
just because that's what I'm most
familiar with so what you can see here
are the various requests that were
captured from the application and all of
our telemetry in the app uses open
census and we can click between a few of
these and so when we look at one of
these so this is a request that a web
browser made to the cart service we can
see how that request was handled across
all these services and so if you weren't
already aware of what distributed
tracing is in my description earlier
wasn't visual enough this should really
show you the power of it so we can see
from here that the requests come into
cart comes into cart but then it has
child requests that go to the currency
service to the recommendation service
and then several times the product
catalog service and then later on again
it hops the currency service so with
this distributed trace we learn a few
things first we understand just a few of
the services and how they interact for
example we know that the cart service
calls the currency service directly and
if we weren't developers of this
application we didn't have intimate
knowledge of how it works the trace is a
really powerful way for us to understand
those interactions without distributed
tracing you effectively can't see those
and the next thing we can understand is
the chain of sort of how these are
chained so we can see that the cart
calls the product catalog service which
then the request goes back to the cart
which then it calls a product catalog
service again and then it calls a
product catalog service again and so on
and so we're trying to optimize their
application this is probably something
we want to fix right this seems really
inefficient when we're reading a single
piece of information from the cart we
might expect maybe the cart has a few
items in it but it seems odd that these
calls aren't bashed or at least done in
parallel and so from just glancing this
distributed trace we've seen a whole
bunch of ways we can improve the latency
of our app and of course this should be
a priority for us this request the cart
took about eight seconds to process
which is awful for an e-commerce system
so Morgan yeah I'm looking at here is
actually a trace from a bunch of
different micro services written in
different languages that's correct yeah
and so again this is part of the power
of real consensus is the support of all
these languages
that's not necessarily something you get
with all third party vendors some really
great support some only focus on a few
languages but with open census we've got
coverage across 8 of the most most used
languages on the web which is really
great oh cool yeah and again just to
reiterate because open says this is an
open source project we're showing this
in stackdriver trace if you were using
Zipkin or a data dogs APM software
something else you'd see a very similar
view so now I'm going to show you how we
got this so we have a function that we
wrote in our code called an it tracing
just so we could encapsulate everything
and inside of an init tracing you can
see where we actually registered open
census we have one line at the top of
this app that just imports the open
census library what we do here is
actually for our trace code we register
an exporter and then we just turn on
open census for tracing and that's it
right I think there's one line down
below where we had to just make a change
to G RPC to enable open census but that
that's 303 line change you've got
distributed Tracy
go ahead there's no tricks here like
it's just this function and in graphs at
the top correct yeah it's really really
straightforward and if this not only are
we capturing the traces and sampling but
we're also doing things like propagating
context automatically so as a developer
with this particular app it's written in
go is really really simple and
straightforward and that's the
experience that we strive for across all
languages it's generally something that
we've achieved if you're using something
like Java and crossing thread boundaries
you do need add like a small amount of
code every time you do that so that we
can just track where how to propagate
context but in general as a developer
the work required here is very very
minimal which is awesome that's like the
core value of open census and with that
you know we were able to capture traces
across our application obviously our
application has some non go components
so it's got Python for that we use open
census Python similar experience you
just import it instantiate it you're
done makes sense
yeah and so it's great and because it's
just a library you can manage this
entirely through source control so
there's no black pocket block there's no
black box agent and youth always update
itself or something you need to set up
on your VM images or in kubernetes you
simply link this to your source code
make a few changes you could version it
and control from there which is great
the next thing I want to show you is
metrics so we've talked a lot about
tracing but open census of course also
does stats and so I'm going to show you
first some of the
metrics that we automatically capture
from the application so as I mentioned
early on this presentation one of the
things that's really really useful in
microservices is understand latency of
every endpoint on every surface this is
not always an easy thing to do
unless you use open census in which case
it is and so what we've got here is a
stat that's automatically captured by
open census this is not a not a stat I
had to define in code as developer or
really do anything for and we're
capturing the G RPC latency for each
endpoint and so you can see here here's
a list of endpoints for the service that
I can stir mint it and you can see the
99th percentile latency this cow chicken
stackdriver you would get the exact same
experience in prometheus or dead dog or
any of the other backends that open
since it supports again we're just an
exact driver because that's what I have
to be the most familiar with and so we
can use this to understand that the
place order method for example is
relatively slow and has a lot of
variants in its 99 percentile latency at
the same time the get product method on
a product catalog service is also slow
but looks like it's 99th percentile
agency is roughly around four seconds
but it has a lot less variance we can
also see though that some parts of the
wrapper relatively fast right they get
quote for the shipping service or list
products from the product catalog
service and so if we're trying to track
the health of our application this can
actually narrow down our investigations
there's a problem in to a particular
endpoint so not just telling us their
app is slow not just telling us that a
certain interaction is slow but a
particular endpoint of a particular
services where the slowdown is and so
this is great for monitoring you can set
alerts and things like this on that on
these metrics it's also great during
those investigations and this is not the
only metric we capture automatically I
think we capture others like the request
size and other latency is generally the
one that we like to demonstrate the most
and to capture this if we jump back to
the code this is what I did up here so
in addition to registering and open
census for tracing I also registered it
for our default G RPC views so this just
captures some basics that GRP see
related stats and I actually did the
instrumentation of this part of the code
myself this was my first time writing go
ever I do a fair amount of programming
other languages just not haven't done it
go much before and I got this done and
about
this and some other work done in above
just under one hour and someone who
doesn't even know the language working
with you know adding adding that some
instrumentation would normally take
forever because you'd have to understand
what you're what you're actually
interacting with for me it was really
really straightforward and so it was
great and it's that same function that
we looked at earlier for instantiating
both tracing and metric correct yeah so
in the open census parlance we call
metrics views is one way to describe a
metric and so for this we just
registered an exporter for review and
then just told it where to go and
subscribe to metrics there's a little
there's you know certainly slightly more
work involved in getting the view going
you just have a few lines of code up
above so actually go in and set things
up for a custom view but for any of the
built in default views it's really
really straightforward
speaking of custom views that's what I'm
going to show you next so we also have a
custom stat that we capture from our
application of of them census you know
as a developer there's there's a huge
amount of value and automatically
capturing things like latency metrics
but we can also let you capture custom
metrics these are often like business
metrics or things like that
for this ecommerce system what we've
captured is the number of items
purchased in a particular checkout
action and so this is average this is
captured over like a one minute time
interval and then Kataeb for that and we
can see over time the number of items
purchase items purchased while we run
our load test that varies numbers of
items purchased ranges between one item
and six items per checkout action over a
minute
and so this is obviously not something
you could ever capture automatically
from your application right business
business metrics like this always have
to be custom defined but open census
also makes that fairly easy so if we go
above we can see here this is where
we've actually gone and defined the
custom view so while of course there's a
little more work than the things that we
automatically capture that's the benefit
of them being automatic these it's still
very very simple to define and register
a custom view inside of your
applications code and again the nice
thing about this being in your apps code
is that it's defined in source control
if you need to make changes version it
roll it back you already have processes
around that and so doing things like you
know registering a new view you can
simply put that in a code review push
that out of production data start
showing up
it was sorrowful there's nothing you
have to do on the backend side that's
correct we simply started sending this
to our back-end in this case stack
driver but you know that could be
Prometheus or something else and nothing
nothing there it'll start it'll start
picking up this new statistic and then
rendering into UI so this is where we
actually register the new view we can
also hop down on the code to where we
actually record it and so this is what
you'll have to write more often right
throughout your code you typically only
need register something once in a
particular service but you want to
record it multiple locations the
recording process is really easy all we
do is look at the length of the order
items array in our code and record that
down to the items purchased for you it's
really really simple and that generates
this really nice graph inside a stack
driver or whatever monitoring solution
were using and so with open census we've
taken something that historically is
very difficult automatically capturing
trace is propagating context it's
actually metadata those traces you know
in addition to all the stuff in the
metric side and we've made it really
simple and straightforward and manacle
through through source control why we're
so excited about the project why we're
talking about it here today so with that
let's hop back to our presentation
finish things up so there are also some
really cool features in open census that
I didn't show you today one of those is
Z pages so Z pages are these sort of
health or status pages that you can
optionally host from the open census
clients themselves what they show you is
the firehose view of stats and RPC
metadata this is information that's not
typically sent to a back-end if you
think of stats sent to the backend or
usually aggregated over a minute or some
other time period to save space and
reduce network congestion and traces as
I mentioned before its ability sampled
right
most companies sample at roughly 1% rate
so the Z pages show you the information
that's not always sent to your back-end
for analysis this is useful if you think
there's an issue for particular service
or a particular instance of a service
but it's not being captured by your
back-end you can jump it up a Z page you
can see everything that's running
through that system and catch any
patterns we're also building some
interaction mechanisms between Z pages
and the open census clients or you can
do things like change the sampling
strategy inside the Z page about having
to redeploy your app we use these of
Google extensively we're actually really
excited to see how people outside of
Google use them
the next thing we have is the w3c trace
context format so about two years ago we
kicked off a small project between
Google and some Zipkin developers to
define a common trace context
propagation format that scents grown to
involve a number of other big companies
like Microsoft diner Tracy and others
context propagation as I mentioned
before is what allows you to actually
get traces across services it's that you
typically a common ID that's used the
link you know when service a talks to
service B B to C C to D and so on that
context that context will be the same
and that's how later on you can process
those to build a single trace the
challenge today is that vendors
typically use their own context
propagation formats so for stackdriver
historically we had a HTTP header called
I think X Google Cloud trace for a
Zipkin they have various HTTP pet
headers that are known as the b3 headers
and so on and so there are a lot of
benefits to having vendors align on a
common context propagation format one of
those is that if you have multiple
vendors participating in a trace let's
say you have different companies and
they want to trace a single interaction
or different parts of a company use
different backends you want those to be
able to communicate the second is sort
of black box tracing so if you have
something like a network load balancer
inside of your application that strips
headers for mange the P requests you'll
break a trace with a common context
propagation format or even just a common
header that won't happen because now we
can work with those vendors and
certainly big names like like Google
Microsoft Dino trace and others we can
achieve this where we can tell those
vendors of like load balancers and other
things to stop stripping headers or so
they stopped stripping this particular
header so the trace will will continue
as we discussed before another really
cool feature of open census is multi
exporter support so you can choose
multiple exporters at once this is
useful in situations where you have
different parts of your organization
using different backends let's say maybe
you use a combination of Zipkin and
Prometheus where you have metrics up to
one status to the other we're sorry
traces to the other and so we can handle
that or if you have even like let's say
you're using like a Zipkin and part of
the company and SolarWinds in another
part or signal FX in another part with
open census you can you can support all
those backends
you don't have to build the
instrumentation three times which is
awesome secondly you can send all the
data it's all backends so if one team
wants to use one back in another team
let's use another you could support that
with open census with very little work
and so the multi exported support is
great it lets you achieve scenarios that
we're really never possible before if I
do extreme amount of work and it also
removes a lot of stickiness where if you
do want to change headers you can do it
with just changing one line of code
which is great are there any differences
in what you can send to the different
exporters generally yeah the the nice
thing in this in this industry lease is
that generally most vendors have similar
notions of what a metric is or what it
traces and so generally everything if
you choose one vendor versus another
basically everything is gonna show up
either way cool and so in theory I guess
you could have some vendors supporting
features that others don't but most of
them all support the same feature set
and for the open census open source
project we've been very adamant that all
features need to support Zipkin and
Prometheus right so we're not going to
add any vendor specific special sauce so
there's not gonna be any sort of like
special stack driver only features and
open census that'd be really bad to the
project everything has to support the
are sort of our sanctioned open source
back-end so now I'm gonna talk about
some of the new features we're
developing for open since it's going
forward everything that I've described
thus far is for the project as it exists
today and so we've already come a long
way and had a lot of success but we're
doing a lot of work over the upcoming
quarters and years the first is really
simple we're just expanding our list of
integrations so getting support for more
client libraries more storage clients
and so on fairly straightforward the
next is this thing called the open
sentence collector service so today open
census just like the backends for
various other vendors there's like just
like the instrumentation various other
vendors since data directly to a
back-end so in that example we had of
service a service be sort of see they
send data directly to stack drive in the
demo that we gave the collector service
will be an optional component that you
can put in between that collects all the
traces and metrics from your application
and then reroute them to your backends
of choice it makes export a
configuration simpler you only have to
do it on the service instead of on each
client it also enables things like
smarter sampling so instead of randomly
say
playing 1% of traces you could sample
after the fact and capture traces that
have high latency for example or traces
associative errors and some other
interesting characteristics which is an
incredibly powerful feature like that
makes tracing dramatically more
effective the other thing it will enable
longer term is quite app support so
support for clients for like iOS Android
Windows run and web and so on where
you'll have those these clients send
telemetry to the open census service
hosted within your application which
then forwards the data back to your
back-end of choice and so that that
allows you to get like traces to have
full and end view all the way from a
front-end web app to read your bet
applications storage layer and so you
can see the actual client perceived
latency rather than just your back-end
ladies really really great next we're
going to expand to more telemetry types
so we've been talking about this for a
while
but we think we want to capture things
like logs and exceptions maybe one day
things like profiles but basically more
and more types of telemetry from from
client applications open census is not
going to be limited to just metrics and
traces that is certainly not a goal the
project we want to capture as much as we
can and send it wherever you want and
finally we want to keep growing the tent
to expand new partners so we announced
at O'Reilly velocity month or two ago
that Microsoft has joined open census
and they're doing the lion's share
development for.net they're also making
some pretty sizable contributions for
Python and I think nodejs and so we're
really excited about that signal FX is
also made and will be making some
contributions and pivotal in particular
is going to be working a lot of
Microsoft on the.net distribution and so
really excited to have them making a big
heavyweight contributions to the project
there were of course also exporters
supported and that have been developed
by third-party companies so data dog
heads they're an exporter solar wind
teaser and exporter in Stata has their
own exporter finally the community has
created exporters for a number of other
backend so for example we can send
traces to AWS x-ray some of the
community contributed that similarly for
Yeager and other backends and so we're
really excited to watch the ecosystem
start to grow open census was started by
Google as historically being a entirely
Google led project we're really excited
to see where it's gonna go if these new
partners involved and with that we're
done the main part of the presentation
so I think we're gonna say
questions we're gonna go offline for a
minute or two and then we'll start
answering questions yep thanks Morgan
and everybody on the livestream stay
tuned for the live Q&A we'll be back in
less than a minute
you
welcome back everyone
we've received a number of questions
from the audience that we're gonna go
ahead and answer for you so the first
one that we got is is there any latency
introduced into the application when
leveraging open census for tracing yeah
that's a good question
we get that question a lot for open
census or any of the telemetry capture
the answer is there's effectively no
measurable latency introduced for
tracing or for metrics it's we've done
measurement since it's basically zero
keep in mind like this is tracing
metrics and census in fact are things
that we use on all services running at
Google so but just for for info you can
you can stay Google fast even while
having you know thousands of levels of
microservices instrumented with census
not a problem
so really no penalty to doing that type
of instrumentation no in general most of
these like unless you're doing things
like profiling where it's constantly on
like in general most telemetry
collection has effectively no impact on
your app if you consume a little bit of
memory maybe like five Meg's of RAM but
no nothing in the critical path for
latency awesome all right next question
what makes open census different from
say Griffin o or other monitoring tools
yes another question that we get very
often so it's really important to keep
in mind open census is just the
telemetry collection so it's just client
libraries that you link to your
application to send Lema tree to another
back-end one of those backends might be
grifone a-- one of those backends might
be zip can or Prometheus or stack driver
or so on there are other projects like
zip canner Prometheus for example which
offer the full end-to-end solution so
Zipkin for example has a back-end for
processing a fairly nice UI that
actually shows you your traces that you
captured Zipkin is a distributed tracing
system and it also has its own
instrumentation open census I think
already has much more breadth of
instrumentation than Sipkins
built an instrumentation from its own
project but it works at Zipkin and so if
you want to use Zipkin you can do that
with open census it's a great way to do
it this way we recommend but yeah the
project's very scope just under serpent
ation next question from the audience
how does open census compare to agent
based instrumentation yes this is
actually a pretty good technical
question so open census like I think
Zipkin and some other tracing solutions
captures your traces from a library that
you linked to your application this has
some positives and negatives so one of
the big benefits that I talked about
during our presentation is that you can
control through source control and so
you can manage through source control
deployments you can do things like link
open census to your app changes version
reconfigure it this is great if you're a
developer because you're already used to
using source control to make changes to
your app and redeploy them roll them
back and so on and so it's very native
to you and you're already using your
built-in your language has built-in
package management management solution
to get open census so ago it's like go
get open census for example and so for
developers this is really native to them
the other benefit of having a library
that's linked to your application is you
can understand how it works right like
all the interfaces that open census
consumes or exposes are visible to you
right and so an open sentence talks of
GRP CEUs the developer are can be pretty
confident that it's not doing some weird
thing you don't understand and it's not
poorly impacting the performance of
graph you can also go and change those
interfaces of you or some reason you
need to it's also open source which
means you can go and modify open census
if there's some kind of like critical
issue that something crops up that like
other other people can't fix in time
agent-based instrumentation on the other
hand which some vendors use is an
executable that you have running in the
background on kubernetes or onto the MS
that hosts your app the one of those
sort of perceived benefits of
agent-based instrumentation is it's
entirely automatic you download and
install this thing you run it and it
just captures traces that captures
metrics they keep itself updated the
challenge is it's hard to version is
agents are typically tied to one of your
VM images that you build or something
like that another challenge is that if
for agents that run on say the JVM for
example they do things like monkey
patching and a lot of sort of weird
instrumentation tricks to get data out
of your app this generally works
relatively well but as a developer you
don't always have confidence that's
going to do everything that you want or
you can never be too sure of its
interactions I'm not trying to bash
database instrumentation the automatic
benefits are tangible like they're real
but we've pretty deliberately chosen to
do things in process with a library that
you link to your code we think it's
better for developers because they can
better manage it and they can see how
things work finally it makes the
instrumentation process
little easier for example for GRP see we
depend on some hooks that the GRCC
client libraries exposed to open census
and what you know we conversion those
and be pretty confident they're not
going to change if you're doing agent
based instrumentation and trying to do
things like monkey patch the JVM it
changes and the things that your
instrumenting can break you even if
they're not of technic not technically a
breaking change and so we're pretty
confident than the long run this is a
much better approach for us got it next
question what happens to my data if
there's an interruption between Open
Census and my back ends yeah generally
this if it's a shorter direction this
isn't a problem so this is defined in
each exporter so I can speak for the
ones that we've written for stackdriver
for example but I think most vendors
have taken care of this in a similar way
that we have typically the export will
do a bit of buffering and retries if you
have an interruption for a large amount
of time some of that data is gonna get
dropped because you know what your
export or an open sense is consuming a
crazy amount of RAM but in general you
know the every vendor is gonna build a
really good logic inside of their
exporter to deal with that we've talked
to some vendors about sharing it but it
seems like most of them have already
built this because for their own
instrumentation they already need to
solve this problem so yeah what
additional telemetry types do you want
to support long term that is it also a
really good question so open census
today does tracing in metrics and
another thing that we call tags that
just you can use to link traces of
metrics but we have much grander
ambitions long-term so one thing that
we're discussing right now with our
partners is support for logging and
exceptions this is a less of a clear-cut
sort of thing for us to do which is why
we're spending the time discussing it as
a group you know trace for traces in
metric collection when we started
development of open census two years ago
there wasn't a lot of prior art there's
certainly a few other projects in this
field but they were either had started
roughly around the same time as us
whether that's like Prometheus are open
tracing in others or they didn't suit
some of our needs but you know if you
look back like before that there really
wasn't anything on the market and so you
know it was a relatively clear decision
to go and develop things in our own when
we look
it's things like logging they're
frameworks like for Java like log4j and
the native Java logging framework and
like tons of others and so what we're
debating now is whether we want to just
integrate with those to be clear we're
already doing some of that work where if
you like open census on Java we
automatically add trace how do you see
your logs right which so you can do
those correlations but what we're really
debating is whether we want to do like
native logging you know consensus so
there'd be like an open sense it's like
log API that you could use to write logs
just like we wrote metrics and traces in
that demo that's something we're trying
to figure out so you know there's
discussions within Google and certainly
the best part with partners like
Microsoft and others about how we
actually want to approach this in
particular we talked about client
applications so we think there's some
pretty big benefits to providing like a
logging in errors API for like iOS and
Android and other clients because
there's not a lot of other equivalents
there whether we want to do that in the
backend is still in debate I suspect we
will do it at the end ok looks like we
have time for one last question
what's the history of the name open
census that's funny you know in other
presentations I've done like a GCP next
in other places I you know I sho open
census in the ecosystem and I show how
you know school open sourced study is gr
PC and Borg became kubernetes and all
these open source projects from Google
but are these cool names the night show
census became open census because
clearly we're not the most creative the
the name of course scent stems from
census which is effectively the same
thing use inside of Google so as I
mentioned it's our libraries that I
automatically collect tracing the
metrics and host there's bork status
pages the uzi pages inside of google the
name how census got its name is not
entirely clear to me I imagine it's just
long predates my time at Google I
suspect it's because it's like oh that's
like a census is when you have a survey
of many many you know entrants or many
many participants and given the number
of machines and processes we have
running in Google it seems somewhat
appropriate and when we wanted to open
source it the team chose that they
wanted to call it open census so not the
most exciting of stories good that's how
the that's how the project got its name
all right well thanks Morgan for
answering those questions welcome thank
you everybody for tuning
today stay tuned for the next session
stream processing with cloud dataflow
SDKs and architectures thank you